[Musique]
bonjour bienvenue au parlement européen
à strasbourg pour un nouveau numéro d'
europe hebdo émission spéciale crise des
migrants l'impasse
les migrants qui tentent encore la
traversée depuis calais pour rejoindre
l'angleterre ils ne renonceront pas
malgré les conditions de vie et les
violences qui ont fait plusieurs blessés
ces derniers jours pour en parler avec
nous dans une première partie nous a
rejoints eva joly bonjour vous êtes
députée européenne du groupe des verts
ici au parlement européen merci d'avoir
accepté notre invitation
avant de débattre je voulais qu'on
regarde ensemble ce reportage c'était la
semaine dernière à calais des bagarres
entre migrants 22 migrants blessés à la
suite de rixes entre afghans est rien
cinq d'entre eux ont été touchés
grièvement par balles ou regarde et on
réagit juste après
un déchaînement de violence inédit coups
de bâton coups de pied une bagarre entre
migrants éclater ce jeudi 1er février à
calais il est 17h30 quand la
distribution de repas est interrompue
l'affrontement a eu lieu à quelques
centaines de mètres de l'ancienne jungle
démantelé à terre un homme blessés
ensanglantés
et tout l'après midi la même violence
deux heures plus tôt près de l'hôpital
plusieurs groupes se sont affrontés et
erythréens contre afghans cette fois ci
avec des armes à feu
bilan 22 blessés dont cinq par balles
hier vers 17h30 on notait au bout de la
route hier on était en train de prendre
notre dîner combes nord comme à chaque
fois d'un coup on a beaucoup les gens de
communautés africaines qu'il sombre nous
aurons ce pad ou dordor d'autres
endroits avec des barrières defra et de
bois et ont commencé à frapper tout le
monde d'avant et rogne al arab
tous les journaux noir donc ils sont
cons ça frappait les gens alors nous
autres surprises
une bataille de territoire entre
passeurs dans un contexte tendu depuis
plusieurs mois selon les associations
les policiers détruisent régulièrement
les petits campements de migrants
c'est une catastrophe il ya beaucoup de
tension qui sont liées à l'hiver qui
sont liés le dispositif hivernal n'est
pas ouvert il ya beaucoup de pressions
policières encore plus forte sur les
tentatives d'installation de campements
et puis elle travail des passeurs qui
essaient de faire leur trafic d'écarter
les gens qui ne payent pas de profiter
voilà deux dossiers de monopoliser des
stations service des parkings et même
des lieux de vie pour gagner de l'argent
gérard collomb s'est rendu sur place les
autorités organiseront désormais des
repas et des douches dans des lieux à
chaque fois différent pour éviter la
création progressive d'un nouveau camp
mais le ministre de l'intérieur est
catégorique il ne veut pas de fixation
des migrants à calais message que je
veux faire passer c'est que si on veut
aller en grande bretagne ce n'est pas
ici qu'il faut venir
notre volonté c'est de se rapprocher le
plus possible du droit qui est celui de
l'allemand
mais jim des pays bas de l'italie qui a
au moins un bloc nation qui coopèrent
ensemble
selon les estimations il y aurait
aujourd'hui entre 600 et 800 migrants à
calais ils étaient plus de 6000 avant le
démantèlement de ce qui fut appelé jadis
la jungle eva joly quand vous voyez si
ces images de violences entre migrants
vous dites quoi
ces images sont terribles et on voit
bien des migrants pousser à bout
ils sont subies dans la nuit la
destruction de leurs sacs de couchage de
leur tente ils se battent au moment de
distribution de repas parce que leur vie
est un calvaire il n'y a pas d'autres
d'autres mots et cette politique là elle
ne mène nulle part
si on croit qu'on va empêcher les
migrants d'essayer d'atteindre
l'angleterre en les privant de tout mais
on se trompe parce que l'attraction de
l'angleterre est je pense irrépressible
ils veulent à l'aide as un pays où ils
comprennent un peu la langue et où ils
ont des attaches
donc c'est un une politique inhumaine
voulons at il dit il faut tolérance zéro
zéro migros est illusoire ccs est
stupide dire tout ça veut dire qu'on ne
comprend rien aux flux migratoires
ce n'est pas parce que on veut faire de
l'europe ou de la france une forteresse
que cela arrêterait les flux migratoires
lorsque les gens n'ont plus à rien à
perdre parce qu'ils vivent dans un
dénuement total dans une totale pauvreté
ou avec des bombes
ils veulent un tout petit peu amélioré
leur chance dans la vie et ils partent
et ce n'est pas la politique de chartres
aux normes qui changera quoi que ça soit
l'as à calais c'était une bagarre de
territoire bagarre entre passeurs et à
l'impératif de lutter contre le
les réseaux de passeurs à les flux
financiers en jeu sont considérables
est-ce qu'il faut pas les traquer
contrat que l'argent de la drogue ou de
la corruption mais certainement les
personnes est en faveur des passeurs il
faut bien comprendre que les migrants
n'ont pas d'autre choix
c'est parce qu'il n'ya pas de voir des
migrations légales c'est qu'il ya pas
pour eux d'autres possibilités qui
d'émettre leur vie entre la entre les
mains des personnes peu recommandables
et d'ailleurs qui se voit mettre leur
vie en péril que cette situation existe
donc il faut créer des voies des
migrations légales c'est ça la réponse à
l'action des passeurs vous appelez à des
solutions dignes pour résoudre la crise
des migrants et des solutions dignes et
une solution européenne de solidarité
vous savez que le parlement nous avons
voté à l'automne cette année à l'automne
2010 est un nouveau texte un texte qui
vise à réformer le texte actuel qui
datait de 94 des accords de double in
les accords existants ont la faiblesse
terrible de rendre responsables d'accor
de deux roues devez faire votre demande
d'asile là où vous êtes rentrée voilà la
première fois et donc c'est une
injustice parce qu'ils rendront en
italie on est entre en italie et grèce
qui sont surchargés
voilà et donc nous avons proposé un
texte qui sort de ces critères et qui
tient compte aussi des l'aspiration des
migrants mais ce texte il est bloqué au
conseil le conseil refuse de discuter à
partir de ce texte
alors c'est quoi la solution cesser ce
blocage est définitive ou pendant des
décennies
vous savez dans les institutions
européennes tout dépend aussi de la
commission tout dépend de la présidence
qui conseille il faut une volonté
politique commune de s'en sortir est de
créer cette solidarité européenne mais
en attendant nous pouvons en france
suspendre les accords de dab line qui
crée des situations insoluble comme l'a
fait l'allemagne en 2015 et nous pouvons
traiter dignement les migrants qui passe
pas notre pays on sait qu'on a le bon
regard en france sur cette crise des
migrants ou c'est en parle beaucoup de
rides
parce que c'est très politique il ya un
aspect populiste insupportable et qu'on
oublie les fondamentaux c'est que nous
avons affaire à des êtres humains en
grande souffrance et qui ont droit à
notre solidarité
merci eva joly d'avoir accepté notre
invitation et maintenant direction
ouistreham nouvelle étape dans le rêve
en anglais des migrants depuis plusieurs
mois de plus en plus de migrants
arrivent dans la cité normande au nord
de caen ouistreham qu'il voit comme une
nouvelle porte d'entrée en angleterre le
reportage sur place de marc labat et
félix ul
[Musique]
chaque jour à la même heure dans ce
petit port du calvados se déroule un
étrange ballet les feux tricolores de
ouistreham ce bloc sur le orange et
c'est la gendarmerie mobile qui fait la
circulation
des dizaines de camions de marchandises
passent à vive allure dans les petites
rues de la ville avec un objectif
empêcher à tout prix qu'un migrant ne
grimpe dans un de leurs containers car à
quelques mètres de là caché derrière un
arbre ou au détour d'une ruelle
une centaine de migrants pour la plupart
originaires du soudan tente
inlassablement de passer de l'autre côté
de cette clôture la porte d'entrée vers
la grande bretagne
toute la journée chauffeur routier
gendarmes migrants joue donc au chat et
à la souris dans ouistreham et à la nuit
tombée le manège s'accélère les
tentatives sont nombreuses les échecs
aussi abdou 33 ans en a bien conscience
il a fui le darfour où une partie de sa
famille a été assassinée
arrivés d'italie il ya une semaine ils
se trouvent obligés de rejoindre
l'angleterre
le seul pays européen qui ne renvoient
pas les migrants dans leurs premiers
pays d'accueil
j'ai pris un bateau pour l'europe mais
il a coulé des gens sont morts
les forces de l'ordre italiennes nous
ont secourus
mais quand nous sommes arrivés en italie
ils nous ont obligés à poser nos
empreintes ci ont refusé ils nous
mettaient en prison où nous battait
comme abdou ils sont des dizaines à
errer dans la ville en attendant que
leurs chances vienne un jour avec
l'hiver les conditions de survie sont
difficiles inhumaines selon miguel qui
habite ouistreham depuis près de dix ans
avec ses voisins il a donc décidé de
leur venir en aide ce soir là juste
après le départ du deuxième ferry de la
journée face à la lassitude voire au
désespoir
le collectif offre un repas chaud des
produits de première nécessité et même
des soit ici on a eu surtout les
réserves d'hygiène est légal et les
savons les shampoings les mouchoirs les
brosses à dents dentifrice rasoir la
crème pour le pour le com uniquement de
quoi faciliter le quotidien car le
collectif c'est que les migrants ne
souhaite pas rester en france
le portique à sion c'est l'angleterre et
l'appel d'air c'est les ferries donc
qu'on s'occupe d'eux qu'on s'occupe pas
d'eux ils sont toujours présents parce
qu'ils veulent aller en angleterre et
rejoindre leurs familles pouvoir
travailler avec l'espoir de reconstruire
une vie quoi ouistreham théâtre d'un
spectacle singulier auquel la
municipalité a choisi de ne pas
participer
s'agissant des adultes
c'est la responsabilité de l'état qui
tous les jours se vient sur terrain avec
des traducteurs dans une volonté de
propositions d'hébergement de
propositions de dossiers à remplir et
même d'accompagnement vers le droit à
l'asile pour ceux qui pourraient
prétendre donc la commune y accompagne
ses démarches
mais la commune ne veut pas endosser une
problématique internationale
nous n'avons pas vocation à accueillir
des migrants sur ouistreham et nous
n'ouvrirons pas d' espaces publics à ces
personnes ici plus que tout la mairie de
ouistreham redoutent qu'une nouvelle
jungle comme celle de calais
n'arrive à émerger malgré tout
[Musique]
alors nous ont rejoints sur ce plateau
deux eurodéputés john shipton darling
bonjour vous êtes députée européenne
britannique du groupe des socialistes et
démocrates merci d'avoir accepté notre
invitation à côté de vous philippe juvin
bonjour vous êtes député européen
français du groupe du parti populaire
européen vous êtes aussi mr les
républicains de la garenne colombes en
région parisienne première question
quand quand vous voyez ce reportage
est-ce que ouistreham est en passe de
devenir à nouveau calé libre juin tout
est possible puisque manifestement pas
de règles pas d'état pour faire
respecter ces règles donc des abcès de
fixation peut se créer partout en france
oui c'est une préoccupation à luis real
aussi jusque dans la nuit
oui je crois qu'il faut garder quand
même une perspective des quais la jungle
à calais étaient évacués il ya eu 6000
gens là dedans et aujourd'hui on est en
train de parler de quelques centaines
d'hommes se sont il faut garder quand
même une hymne perspective les tailles
de choses je crois que le coopération
entre le royaume uni et la france
si ça fonctionne bien et dans le cadre
de l'union européenne il ya moyen que ça
ne vient pas au même contexte grenelle
on a vu ces migrants ne renonce pas et
veulent à tout prix rejoindre
l'angleterre pourquoi selon il faut
aussi garder un perspectives relatives
l'année passée il ya eu sans me demander
si l'enfance il ya eu 27 mai le demander
si l'homme on l'embêté au royaume uni en
général le taux d'acceptation était le
même dans les deux pays d'oc
c'est plus facile d'être accepté on
envahit min et qu'on voit beaucoup de
migrants veux rester en france aussi est
vrai aussi les associations disent
qu'ils veulent rejoindre l'angleterre il
y aura un système de cartes d'identité
qui permet aux individus d'être moins
suivi qu'en france est plus facile d
c'est plus facile de travailler
illégalement en angleterre
je crois que pour certaines la question
des quatre des dandys tellement de
cartes d'identité jumet par le plus
passer une question d
les alliances familiales les connexions
locales
le zoo on attend du projet des enfants
qui veulent rejoindre les familles en
angleterre ça je crois que c'est un plus
grand débat que les questions délicates
du don du thé et le travail illégal
parce que pour la plupart des gens les
questions de vivre dans l'égalité c'est
pas un rêve c'est pas qu'est ce qu'il
veut il veut avoir une vie qui me lisent
habité donc je crois que pour le plus
passent et les connexions avec le
royaume uni c'est vraiment un connexion
peut-être de langue d'histoire des
connexions culturelles et de familles
qui sont déjà ramené juin oui donc ils
veulent passer la majorité des gens qui
sont à carhaix veulent passer au
royaume-uni pas une surprise on le sait
et vous parlez de collaboration franco
britannique
nous la souhaitons mais nous avons
vraiment le sentiment que les
britanniques se défont sur la france de
leurs propres obligations
prenons l exemple en 2016 il ya une
décision politique
une renégociation entre le premier
ministre britannique et le président
français françois hollande sur
l'admission d'un certain nombre de
migrants illégaux présents à calais sur
le territoire du royaume uni à l'époque
la grande bretagne avait dit nous allons
prendre trois mille personnes au titre
essentiellement du regroupement familial
ou des mineurs 3000 personnes
aujourd'hui nous en parlons nous sommes
un an plus tard moins de 10 % des gens
sont passés donc je pense qu'il ya une
volonté du royaume uni pas jouer le jeu
et de se débarrasser sur la france de
ses obligations de frontières
et très franchement avec le break site
moi je dis aux britanniques vous avez
vous lu votre indépendance voulait
reprendre le contrôle de vos frontières
bien reprenez vos frontières
je crois que il y à un vérité là dedans
le vrai mini a fait la corse et les 3000
et mon parti au parlement britannique a
voulu vraiment comprendre notre
obligation au mans le parti travailliste
avec les mets pour prendre beaucoup des
gens qui avaient le lien familial au le
mineur pratiquement le mineur qui sont
pas à contenir qui sont vraiment en
danger sur la situation actuelle
nous on a eu envie de prendre notre
responsabilité
on a un problème avec notre gouvernement
ça je j'avoue et donne la situation du
brésil
le problème c'est qu'aujourd'hui on a un
cadre européenne qui dans une manière
ont battu le débat par l'émigration des
consorts vous avez raison il ya un grand
banquet
qu'est ce que va suivre et c'est normal
que je trouve un vu la situation le fait
que le gouvernement a pas respecté
l'accord de 2016
il ya un côté de le côté français qui
dit ok après petit vous êtes un tout
seul allez l'indépendance fait qu'est ce
que vous voulez le problème pour nous
c'est notre gouvernement voie le il voit
la pression des voteurs qui ont qui ont
vu les images de nigel farrage et des
équipes d'avant le goût vendent les
grandes villes beau de le guen des
posteurs dans le but par la migration de
la série et donne le départ par robert
gibbs a joué un rôle joue un rôle de les
années folles il faut être honnête la
crise de migros a conduit au brésil
oui le numéro grand oui oui oui
certainement donc ça joue dans le
politique de leur gouvernement
britannique est de notre côté on est
très critique selon notre propre
gouvernement
nous de notre côté on voit qu'elle leur
pensait d'eux
donner l'argent à la france les français
donnent en voile ton accords de san
andrés 45 millions nouveaux la livre
britannique qui souvent ne voyait
prendre la défense
comprenez que la france ne peut pas être
le garde-frontière de la grande bretagne
nous pouvons pas faire le sale boulot
c'est trop bien l'intérieur avait dit
take my money back
oui c'est moche détecté au bord 2 back
my money back vouloir renégocier des
accords du touquet pour que les
britanniques prennent leur part dans
l'accueil des réfugiés
moi il me semble que en plus avec le
break site en plus avec le non respect
de leurs engagements par les
britanniques depuis quelques années
alors qu'on avait essayé de trouver des
solutions il faut être assez ferme avec
nos voisins
ils reprennent leurs frontières ils
reprennent leur contrôle de leurs
frontières
ils assument leurs obligations et nous
ne sommes pas les gardes frontières
britanniques le douanier français n'est
pas le douanier à la mercenaire un
mercenaire britannique
ça c'est absolument certain vous savez
ces sujets sont très complexes je ne
méconnais pas que ce n'est pas comme ça
que ça va se régler
mais c'est vrai nous n'avons pas à
porter seules le poids le poids
considérable de ces affaires là
évidemment il faut améliorer d'abord les
conditions d'accueil des migrants à
calais quand le président de la
république dit qu'on va donner des repas
entre nous et heureusement
heureusement évidemment il faut
améliorer les délais d'instruction des
dossiers qui sont beaucoup trop longs je
suis frappé de voir que les demandes
d'asile en allemagne sont traités en
quelques jours
en quelques jours nous six mois un an un
an et demi et comment voulez vous
renvoyer dans son pays d'origine
quelqu'un qui est là depuis un an et
demi en pratique on sait que ça ne se
fait pas il n'y a pas de renvoi dans le
pays d'origine
c'est une c'est une mesure d'ordre
malheureusement théorique c'est ainsi
donc il faut raccourcir les délais
l'instruction il faut refoulé d'emblée
tous ceux qui viennent de pays sur
pardon l'albanie est candidate à
l'entrée dans l'union européenne
et il ya des
des immigrés des émigrés des immigrés
chez nous albanais qui arrivent en
disant nous sommes en danger notre pays
si l'albanie
ce sont des migrants économiques n'est
pas dépendant pas des tant elle est
riche dans l'union européenne il faut
qu'elle règle cette question il faut des
guichets dans les pays de départ bref
photos des tas de mesures mais en même
temps il faut clairement que les
britanniques prennent leurs
responsabilités qu'ils ont toujours
refusé jusqu'ici je ne vous met pas du
tout en cause je sais que vous êtes en
désaccord avec votre propre gouvernement
mais trop c'est trop j'ai craqué il faut
il ya jamais une solution qui est très
simple et je crois que j'ai vraiment les
craintes que les idées que la corpiq est
complètement déchiré et abandonner c'est
que on va voir les vies de gens vendu
beaucoup plus long jeu va pas régler le
problème au nord de la france le
problème assure elle vêtue et là on va
voir le voyage beaucoup plus dangereux
de gens dans le manche est et là je
crois qu'il ya c'est là que la
coopération franco britannique est
vraiment important peut-être l'accord tu
avais regardées je crois que la côte de
san jose qui étaient négociés en janvier
par président mac en crise mais ça
montre qu'il ya il ya toujours une
évolution de la relation
j'espère que notre gouvernement va
prendre ses responsabilités ses
obligations mieux en main mais je crois
que cette coopération de dire abandonnez
vous reprendre les frontières c'est sa
règle pas le problème je crois que ça va
continuer la situation actuelle on a
besoin d'une approche un petit je suis
désolé d'utiliser le mot un petit peu
plus mûr et un petit peu plus plus
détaillée
c'est le problème parce que à la fin
c'est les gens vous avez raison oui mais
déjà les causses et les vies de gens
qu'on est en train de parler et quand tu
vois les conditions dans lesquelles
c'est un genre le petit enfant tombe
parfois habite et le voyage qu'ils
essaient de faire passer ça nous oblige
comme politicien de trouver une solution
qui est plus durable et de bouffon et de
fos le gouvernement de prendre les
obligations qu'ils sont engagés à
prendre évidemment mais comme vous le
dit fort justement le premier désaccord
du touquet et de tous les accords qui se
sont greffées sur les accords du touquet
c'est que ils ne sont pas respectées
vous parlez des mineurs la grande
bretagne devait accueillir 3000 mineurs
et ne les a pas accueilli donc je veux
bien qu'on viennent pleurer sur les
mineurs qui sont à calais et qui sont
dans une situation tragique tragique et
dangereuse vous avez raison mais en même
temps il faut en tirer les conséquences
et assumer les obligations qu'on a
prétendu vouloir assumer il ya un an
c'est ça que nous reprochons britannique
c'est de ne pas assumer en fait leur
part du travail en aveugle a dû qu'à
franco britannique en particulier la
crise des migrants général cas concret à
ce qu'ils obtiennent donc le droit de
rester les autres majoritaires qui ne
l'obtiennent pas on fait quoi on les
renvoie en italie ou en grèce de là où
ils sont venus où ils vont venir
pas même le quart retournent dans leur
pays d'origine où l'idée alors
légalement comme vous l'avez rappelé le
droit européen dit que dès lors qu'ils
sont qui ne doivent pas être accueilli
en france parce que leur demande a été
refusée
ils doivent repartir dans le pays
européen qui les a accueillis
géographiquement en fait c'est l'italie
ou la grèce
mais cette situation ne peut pas durer
tout simplement pourquoi parce que ça
fait porter tout le fardeau de
l'immigration illégale non traitées à la
grèce et l'italie
donc ça ne peut pas marcher ça signifie
qu'il ya pas de politique européenne en
fait et donc ce que je crois c'est
qu'ils vont revenir sur les accords de
dublin
très clairement mais en même temps
parallèlement sinon ça ne marche pas je
l' ai dit tout à l'heure raccourcir les
délais parce ce qui fait qu'on ne
renvoie pas les étrangers en situation
irrégulière chez eux c'est qu'on met du
temps à répondre à leur demande d'asile
encore une fois quand vous mettez un an
deux ans trois ans pour répondre à une
demande d'asile au bout d'un an deux ans
trois ans les enfants sont allés à
l'école et j'ai retrouvé une situation
certains ont réussi à se stabiliser et
vous ne pouvez pas humainement les
renvoyer d'ailleurs vous ne les voyez
pas vous ne voyez pas on peut toujours
dire oui il faut renvoyer les gens ça ne
marche pas donc moi je vous dis il faut
traiter le dossier en quelques jours en
allemagne
ces sept jours le traitement d'un
dossier d'asile sept jours et quand il
ya un appel qu un jour de plus en france
six mois un an et un rapport
parlementaire qui a dit que 2 à 5 % des
étrangers en situation irrégulière
reconnu comme en situation irrégulière
5% simplement étaient renvoyés dans leur
pays d'origine
on voit très bien que notre système ne
fonctionne pas donc il faut profondément
de modifier d'ailleurs je comprends
pourquoi les britanniques sont très
inquiets de la sphère du brics et c'est
que avec le bric site
enfin à dans l'union européenne il
bénéficie de dublin
donc ils peuvent dire on n'a pas à les
renvoyer chez eux on les envoie en
italie en grèce juste titre dance avec
le brix avec et la gestion de la crise
des migrants avait qu un royaume uni en
dehors de l'union européenne
mais je crois bien entre nous les
questions de quelle réglementation va
rester après brigitte c'est vrai on joue
dans le débat national parce qu'elles
sont des blancs on serait obligé de
prendre leurs responsabilités pour tout
le monde qui arrive en territoire
britannique et donc je vois dans la
course en tête que la déjà le
gouvernement
mais en place essayez de met en place
une une accord qui va agir après
brigitte mais j'imagine par la france
pour doper ils vont pas accepter on ne
respecte pas nos obligations de notre
côté on ne peut pas avoir les avantages
du breakbeat et garder les avantages de
l'europe mais j'y suis désolé mais ça
c'est la prochaine à tuer comme le mans
s'est beaucoup de ces jeunes
nouvellement je ne sais pas mais c'est
un vrai sujet allez on termine par notre
rubrique de fact checking à lors du
forum économique mondial à davos le
président américain donald trump a
fustigé la politique commerciale de
l'union européenne envers son pays alors
l'union européenne boutel les produits
américains c'est checkpoint préparer
aujourd'hui par adeline
loubini les relations commerciales entre
les états unis et l'union européenne
sont toujours tendus lors du forum
économique mondial à davos le président
américain donald trump a fustigé la
politique commerciale de l'union
européenne envers son pays
ce trader de faire entrer nos produits
dans l'union européenne pourtant elle
envoie se produit chez nous il ya très
peu de taxes l'union européenne est très
injuste envers les états unis
alors l'union européenne est-elle en
froid avec le marché américain pour
savoir s'il ya un déséquilibre dans le
commerce entre ces deux puissances
économiques
il faut regarder la balance commerciale
une balance qui est clairement en faveur
de l'union européenne en 2016 faux
exportations pour les états unis ont
représenté 3 118 milliards d'euros c'est
60% de plus que les états unis qui eux
n'ont envoyé que pour cent le nombre
similaire vers l'europe
résultat un déficit de 122 milliards
d'euros pour les américains mais d'une
manière générale les états unis importe
plus qu'ils n'exportent et pas seulement
avec l'union européenne
ils sont le premier pays importateur au
niveau mondial et leur balance
commerciale globale affiche un déficit
de près de 724 milliards d'euros alors
l'union européenne taxe tel trop les
produits américain donald trump dénonce
les taxes européennes trop élevé par
rapport aux américaines selon lui
pourtant les niveaux de taxation sont
équivalents entre les deux parties 2 3%
en moyenne pas de grosse différence donc
alors l'europe at-elle des normes trop
strictes pour exporter un produit il n'y
a pas que la taxation qui entrent en jeu
il faut également respecter certaines
réglementations certaines normes et
l'europe est souvent pointé du doigt de
l'autre côté de l'atlantique avec ses
normes considéré comme trop restrictive
mais de nouveau les chiffres montrent
que sur ce point les deux parties sont
sur un pied d'égalité
alors l'union européenne défavorisés
tels les états unis n'a ces échanges
commerciaux c'est plutôt faux voilà
c'est la fin d'europe hebdo merci à vous
deux d'être venus débattre avec nous
c'était passionnant merci à vous de nous
avoir suivis restez avec nous sur les
chaînes parlementaires et la rtbf bail
[Musique]